OF THE HEARING TO ORDER AND ASK
FOR EXAMPLE CALL PLEASE.
ALL RIGHT.
THERE.
FLORA.
CARILLO [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
GONZALEZ.
JONES AWYER.
THREE OF US.
HELLO MISTER WHICH THANK YOU AND
I WANT TO THANK YOUR SUMMER
QUIRK FOR YOUR TO TIMELINESS AS
USUAL -- AND
WE CAN GOING TO START --
WITH A. B. FOUR FIFTY SEVEN
RELATED TO OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY
AND HEALTH.
RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT OF THIS BILL WILL
AUTHORIZE THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL REV.
JUST TO RELATIONS TO REGULATE
THE PERMISSIBLE EXPOSURE LEVEL
FOR LED BY DATE CERTAIN.
OF THEIR NUMEROUS LED RELATED
CLEANUP PROJECTS AROUND THE
STATE INCLUDING A HUNT TEN
THOUSAND PROPERTIES AROUND EXIDE.
SOMETHING THAT YOUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS KNOW A LOT ABOUT.
AND LEAD PAINT READ --
REMEDIATION.
WE ASK WORKERS LEAD TO PROTECT
NEARBY COMMUNITIES WE NEED TO
ENSURE.
THAT WE ARE ALSO PROTECTING THE
WORKERS CAL OSHA HAS BEEN
WORKING ON THE PERMISSIBLE
EXPOSURE EXPOSURE LEVEL SINCE
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN WHEN WE
ALREADY KNEW IT NEED TO BE FIXED.
BUT THERE IT REGULATIONS HAVE
YET TO BE UPDATED THE RESEARCH.
TO SET THE ACCEPTABLE EXPOSURE
LIMITS HAS ALREADY BEEN DONE
THAT ROUTE THAT WORK WAS
FINISHED IN NOVEMBER OF TWENTY
SIXTEEN SO AS THE ECONOMIC
ANALYSIS.
THE WORK IS DONE.
WE KNOW THAT WERE EXPOSING
WORKERS TO TO HIRE LEAD EXPOSURE
LEVEL --
EIGHT YEARS IS LOCKED TO LONG TO
WAIT.
HERE WITH ME TODAY --
FROM THE COUNCIL OF LABOR'S IS
KATIE DONNA YOU TO RAM.
THANK YOU SOME ACCORDING I
DIDN'T MENTION EARLIER BUT IF
FOR EACH --
ITEM.
YEAH YOU HAVE A UP TO SIX
MINUTES I'LL TAKE IT ALL BUT I'M
JUST MAKE SIX MINUTES DIVIDED
AMONGST HOW VERY MANY WITNESSES
YOU HAVE IN THIS CASE OFFICE WE
HAVE ONE WITNESS.
BUT AS ONE ABOUT THAT OUT THERE
FOR ABOUT SMALL.
ALL RIGHT I'M SURE SHE CAN
FINISH IN TWO MINUTES.
OR LESS FOR LESS GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
KATIE DON'T HE HOOKED AROUND
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL LABORS HERE IN SUPPORT
OF AB --
FOUR FIFTY SEVEN AS YOU HER
DOCTOR QUIRK STATES BEEN EIGHT
YEARS SINCE THE ROLE MAKING
BEGAN FOR THE REVISION TO THE
PERMISSIBLE EXPOSURE LIMIT FOR
LEAD.
IN THE CURRENT STANDARD IS BASED
ON THAT MORE THAN THIRTY FIVE
YEARS OLD.
OUR MEMBERS PARTICIPATE IN LEAD
ABATEMENT AND CLEAN UP WORK ON A
VARIETY OF SITES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
MOREOVER THE RECENT DESTRUCTIVE
WILDFIRES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
HAVE LEFT TALKS EXTRA TOXIC
DEBRIS BEHIND AND THESE MASSIVE
CLEANUP EFFORTS ONLY ADD TO THE
EXPOSURE THAT OUR MEMBERS FACED.
WITHOUT A DEADLINE FOR
COMPLETING THE PO RULE MAKING
WORKERS RISK NOT HAVING SCIENCE
BASED LEAD EXPOSURE THRESHOLDS
UNDER WHICH TO WORK SAFELY NEWS
FOR THESE REASONS THAT WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FREE AYE VOTE
TODAY.
THANK YOU --
ANYONE ELSE OR MORE LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS.
ALLOW YOUR FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP I APOLOGIZE FOR
NOT GETTING A LETTER IN YET AND
IN THE CRUNCH OF THE LAST FEW
WEEKS BUT THIS IS IMPORTANT BILL
IT'S A HAS TO DO WITH.
MAKING SURE THEIR STANDARDS ARE
TIGHT AND IT'S ABOUT TIME CAL
OSHA GOT TO THIS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR INTRODUCING IT THANK
YOU --
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
RIGHT IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
FOR THE CAL CHAMBER AND WE ARE
OPPOSED AND LESS AMENDED --
FIRST TO CLARIFY THE CHAMBERS OF
COURSE NOT AGAINST OSHA
REGULATING LEAD --
REVISING STANDARDS OR EVEN DOING
SO IN A MORE TIMELY MANNER AS
THE AUTHOR HAS --
DISCUSSED --
WHAT WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
REALLY IS THAT WE DON'T WANT THE
TIMING OF THIS GET IN THE WAY OF
GETTING IT RIGHT --
AND WE'VE SPOKEN TO THE AUTHOR
STAFF ABOUT THIS AND STAFF HAS
BEEN WELCOMING OF A DISCUSSION
GOING FORWARD --
TO PICK MAYBE A DATE THAT'S NOT
THE FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY
PRESENT PROPOSAL BUT POTENTIALLY
A A BIT MORE OUT AND FIND A
WORKING DAY SO WE ARE THANKFUL
FOR THAT AND WE LOOK FOR TO
TALKING STAFF GOING FORWARD --
BRIEFLY AND I WILL CERTAINLY NOT
USED LOT IT --
BUT BRIEFLY THE ONE OUR PRIME
CONCERNS ABOUT --
ACCELERATING THIS PROCESS
PARTICULARLY IS BECAUSE AS THE
AUTHOR MENTIONED THERE IS AN
ONGOING RULE MAKING PROCESS IT'S
BEEN GOING FOR SOME TIME.
IT'S PRETTY SYSTEMATIC AND
CHANGES IN THE THIS BILL
PRESENTLY ONLY ADDRESSES
ACCELERATING THAT P. E. L.
CHANGES.
I BELIEVE THE INTENT IS TO
ADDRESS ALL OF THOSE AREAS AND
BECAUSE OF THE DRASTIC NATURE OF
THOSE CHANGES THAT ARE ON THE
TABLE AND THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
DRESSED IN ALL OF THEM.
I THINK IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE WE TAKE
THE TIME TO ALLOW THE NECESSARY
COMMON.
BUT AS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR --
A LEAVE THAT THERE AND FOR THESE
REASONS WE ARE OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE OPPOSITION.
OKAY WILL BRING IT BACK. TO THE
COMMITTEE AND WE DO HAVE A
MOTION.
OF FROM SUMMER GONZALEZ SECONDED
BY SUMMER CARILLO DO PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS.
IF THERE'S NO FURTHER COMMENT
ALLOW SOME RECORD. TO CLOSE ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU I HOPE TO GET
YOUR AYE VOTE.
OKAY SO THIS IS MY
RECOMMENDATION UP FROM THE CHAIR --
MOTION ON THE FLOOR TO PASS
HELLO.
DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
KALRA AYE KALRA AYE FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING CREEL.
CARILLO HI DEEP [inaudible]
GONZALEZ.
SALAS I'D JONES SAWYER THREE OF
US.
THREE OF US I PRESS THE BILLS
OUT THANK YOU.
YEAH WE CAN HAVE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THEIR TWO ITEMS
ON CONSENT A. B. TWO SIXTY SEVEN
SUMMER.
YOU AND EIGHTY FIVE NINETY THREE
SOME AMBER KOREA.
IT'S OUR SECOND.
I'D.
CALDERON PRESENT [inaudible]
AB.
TWO AB TWO SIXTY SEVEN MOTION IS
TO PASS CONSENT TO THE ARTS
COMMITTEE KALRA.
ALL RIGHT I FLORA FLORA I
CARILLO.
CARILLO I DEEP.
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I JONES
SAWYER THREE OF US.
THREE OF US HI.
THE MOTION ON A. B. FIVE NINETY
THREE IS TO PASS CONSENT TO
APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible]
KALRA HI.
KALRA AYE FLORA FLOOR I CARILLO.
CARILLO I DEEP.
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I JONES
SAWYER.
THREE OF US THREE OF US I ALL
RIGHT --
THANK YOU A SUMMER GONZALEZ AB.
FIVE NINE OF A BILL TO GET
RELATED TO EMPLOYMENT.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN.
AND TWENTY SIXTEEN A SAN DIEGO
BASED COUPLE WAS ARRESTED FOR
ENSLAVING AN INDONESIAN DOMESTIC
WORKER IN THEIR HOME.
FORCING HER TO WORK BETWEEN
SIXTEEN TO EIGHTEEN HOURS A DAY
WITH NO PAY AND NO DAYS OFF.
THE VIEWS THE VICTIM MENTALLY
AND PHYSICALLY BY RETAINING HER
PASSPORT MAKING HER BELIEVE IT
SHOULD BE PHYSICALLY HARMED IF
SHE DID NOT PERFORM HER DUTIES.
A TWENTY FOURTEEN URBAN
INSTITUTE STATE FOUND THAT MANY
VICTIMS OF LABOR TRAFFICKING ARE
SUBJECT TO A VARIETY OF PHYSICAL
AND PSYCHOLOGICAL TACTICS MEANT
TO CONTROL AND ENSLAVE THE
VICTIMS.
INCLUDING THE USE OF DOCUMENT
SERVITUDE.
DOCUMENT SERVITUDE AS A PRACTICE
OF AN EMPLOYER OCCUPANTS FOR THE
PURPOSE OF MANIPULATING THE
EMPLOYEE.
WITH THE VAST MAJORITY LABOR
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS BEING
IMMIGRANTS IT IS VITAL THAT THE
CALIFORNIA PROTECT THESE WORKERS
BY PREVENT TEEN UNSCRUPULOUS
EMPLOYERS BIG AND SMALL FROM
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THESE
WORKERS IMMIGRATION STATUS.
AB FIVE EIGHTY NINE TO HELP
PROTECT WORKERS AGAINST THE MORE
PRACTICE OF DOCUMENT SERVITUDE
BY PROVIDING A FRAMEWORK TO HOLD
EMPLOYERS ACCOUNTABLE WHO ENGAGE
IN DOMESTIC SERVITUDE.
INDETERMINATE VIOLATION IS A
MISDEMEANOR POTENTIAL TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS CIVIL PENALTY.
WOULD ALSO ESTABLISH WORKERS
BILL RIGHT SO MUCH THE EMPLOYER
MUST PROVIDE A COPY TO EVERY
WORKER IN THEIR LANGUAGE OF
CHOICE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
BUT WITNESSES PART SORRY.
HI HI MARTIN OIL I'M A DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY --
AND THE SEX CRIMES AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING DIVISION OF THE
SENATE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
DISTRICT ATTORNEY SUMMER STEPHAN.
UP FEDERAL ALREADY HAS A SIMILAR
PROVISION AS THE COMMITTEE NOW
SAYS THE NOTES WHICH PROHIBITS
WITHHOLDING GOVERNMENT DOCUMENTS
AND PASSPORTS TO FURTHER
VIOLATIONS OF FEDERAL LAW WITH
RESPECT TO LABOR TRAFFICKING.
EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY NINE WOULD BE
ANOTHER TOOL FOR DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS AND CITY ATTORNEYS. TO
COMBAT UNSCRUPULOUS EMPLOYERS
WOULD SEEK TO BENEFIT FROM A
HOLDING THEIR EMPLOYEES
IMMIGRATION DOCUMENTS AB FIVE A
FIVE EIGHTY NINE WOULD PROHIBIT
WITH HOLY OF IMMIGRATION
DOCUMENTS TO FURTHER A VIOLATION
OF STATE LAW.
WELL WE ALREADY HAVE A LABOR
TRAFFICKING FELONY --
PENAL CODE SECTION TWO SIXTY ONE
SUBDIVISION A FOR SOMEONE WHO
DEPRIVE SOMEONE OF THEIR
PERSONAL LIBERTY TO OBTAIN
FORCED LABOR.
THIS BILL WOULD CREATE A
MISDEMEANOR FOR WITHHOLDING
DOCUMENTS DISCOURAGE SOMEONE FOR
EXERCISING ANY ANY OF THEIR
LABOR EMPLOYEE RIGHTS UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW.
IT WOULD ALSO INFORM EMPLOYEES
MANY OF WHOM COME FROM PLACES
WHERE THEY DID NOT HAVE SUCH
RIGHTS OF THEIR RIGHTS IN
CALIFORNIA.
AS A PROSECUTOR I OFTEN FIND
THAT VICTIMS ARE RELUCTANT TO
COME FORWARD.
BECAUSE OF THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS.
THE LEGISLATURE BRING THESE
PEOPLE OUT OF THE DARKNESS --
AND GIVING THEM ACCESS TO OUR
SYSTEM BY ACTING A PRIVILEGE IN
THE EVIDENCE CODE AGAINST USING
SOMEBODY'S --
IMMIGRATION STATUS MERELY.
FOR IMPEACHMENT PURPOSES AND
ALSO THEY'VE AMENDED THE
EXTORTION STATIC STATUTE TO MAKE
IT SO PEOPLE CAN'T BE EXTORTED.
BASED ON IMMIGRATION STATUS.
THIS IS ANOTHER STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OF ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF A PUBLIC COMMENT
ACOSTA THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU YEAH AND WE ALSO
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERS
MITCH DYER WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS RENE
BAYARDO IS HERE YOU CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANDRE RIVER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. FOR
ANYONE OPPOSITION.
YES.
HELLO AGAIN ROBERT MUTRIE --
FOR THE CAL CHAMBER WE ARE
OPPOSED TO AB --
FIVE EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY FIVE
EIGHTY NINE WOULD BURDEN
MILLIONS OF EMPLOYEES ACROSS THE
STATE BECAUSE OF THE ADMITTEDLY
TERRIBLE ACTIONS OF A FEW --
GOVERNOR BROWN TO VETO MESSAGE
LAST YEAR TO A SIMILAR PASSAGE
CONTAINED IN AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY TO PLAY THIS OUT.
A QUOTE THE VAST MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIAN PLAYERS HAVE NOTHING
TO DO WITH LABOR TRAFFICKING SO
THIS MANDATE AS APPLY TO THEM IS
BURDENSOME I ON WARRANTED --
AND YOU KNOW AS AN EASY EXAMPLE
OF SAN DIEGO AND OTHER HIGH RISK
AREAS CLEARLY ARE YOU KNOW.
VERY DISTINCT FROM LET'S SAY THE
TECH SECTOR IN IN SAN FRANCISCO
OR A FAMILY GROCERY STORE IN
REDDING OR OR EUREKA --
SO BECAUSE OF THE BURDEN TO ALL
EMPLOYERS WE BELIEVE THIS IS
UNWARRANTED AT THIS TIME --
ONE ADDITIONAL CONCERN WHICH WE
RACE WITH STAFF --
THOUGH IT --
ABOUT THIS BILL IS THE MOST OF
THE RIGHTS DELINEATED IN THE
BILL OF RIGHTS --
THE FIRST SECOND FOURTH AND
FIFTH AREN'T PROBLEMATIC THE
THIRD ACTUALLY CREATES --
A RIGHT WHICH AND ALL ALL READ
THE LANGUAGE TO BE PRECISE THE
RIGHT TO LIVE --
IS LOOSELY THE RIGHT TO LIVE
WHEREVER THE EMPLOYEE CHOOSES
NOW IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
EXAMPLE PROVIDED WE CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND HOW THAT WOULD BE
PROBLEMATIC --
THE EMPLOYERS CONCERN IS THAT
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF EMPLOYMENT
SITUATIONS WHERE LIVING IN A
LOCATION IS IS KEY AND
CALIFORNIA WAGE ORDERS AND
FEDERAL LAW RECOGNIZES
SITUATIONS LIKE --
AN ONSITE APARTMENT MANAGER
RIGHT WHO NEEDS TO BE AROUND
BECAUSE PART OF THEIR JOB IS
BEING PRESENT FOR THOSE
SITUATIONS --
ANOTHER EXAMPLE THAT --
AND I I'VE AGAIN WILL NOT TAKE
SIX MINUTES WITH THIS BUT
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF A GOOD FRIEND
OF MINE WENT THROUGH WAS WORKING
AS A GARDEN INDUSTRIAL PLANT IN
STOCKTON WHERE HE NEEDED TO BE
ON SITE THAT NIGHT OTHERWISE
SOMEONE WOULD STEAL THE
EQUIPMENT AND SO HE SLEPT AND
STAYED.
AT THAT SITE WHILE HE WAS DOING
THAT JOB I DON'T BELIEVE THOSE
OF THE YOU KNOW THE INTENDED
CONSEQUENCE HERE BUT THE CHAMBER
IS A CONCERN THAT THIS COULD
LEAD TO UNINTENDED LITIGATION
FOR EMPLOYERS WHO.
ARE NOT REALLY THAT AIM HERE --
SO BECAUSE OF THAT BURDEN AND
BECAUSE OF THAT CONCERN OVER ON
INTENT LITIGATION OF THE BILL OF
RIGHTS YOUR POST THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE OPPOSITION.
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
BILL GIVENS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION WE
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON THIS BILL WELL WE
APPRECIATE THE AND TEND TO THE
LEGISLATION --
WE'RE NOT AWARE OF ANY INSTANCES
OF VIOLATIONS OF OF WHAT HAS
BEEN GIVEN AS AN EXAMPLE --
HAPPENING WITH PUBLIC AID
SUGGESTED MOMENT IS TO SIMPLY
REMOVE PUBLIC AGENCIES FROM THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THIS BILL WE
BELIEVE THAT THE COST OF
COMPLIANCE AND RECORD KEEPING
THE POTENTIAL LIABILITY.
OUTWEIGH THE BENEFITS OF
APPLYING THIS TO PUBLIC AGENCIES
AND AND SO WE'RE REQUESTING BE
REMOVED FROM THE BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
RIGHT LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION FOR THE REASON
STATE ABOUT MY COLLEAGUE AND CAL
CHAMBER IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OKAY LET ME BACK TO
THE COMMUNITY TO HAVE A MOTION
FROM SUMMER CARILLO SECOND BEST
MOVIE BEST ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
AND AND I WANT TO THANK THE
SUMMER FOR BRING THIS BILL BACK
AGAIN I SUPPORT IT LAST TIME I
DO HAVE AN AYE RECOMMENDATION.
AND JUST TO THE CONTENTION OF
THIS IS ONLY A BORDER ISSUE OR
AN ISSUE THAT APPLIES TO A
SPECIFIC INDUSTRY I I WOULD I
REALLY --
ABSOLUTE DISAGREE WITH THAT --
WE HAD OF A REALLY EGREGIOUS
HUMAN TRAFFICKING CASE WHERE THE
HEART OF MY DISTRICT --
TOWER THAT WAS WILL CALL SILVERY
TOWERS THAT WAS NICKNAMED
SLAVERY TOWERS BECAUSE THEY
LITERALLY ENSLAVED PEOPLE WOULD
NOT LET THEM LEAVE --
BUT IT AND WE'RE NOT PAYING THEM
AND IT WAS JUST A PERFECT CASE
SO THAT'S ONE OF MANY MANY MANY
BE SEEN IN SILICON VALLEY ACROSS
A NUMBER OF INDUSTRIES SO.
ALTHOUGH I RESPECT THE CONCERN
IN TERMS OF WHETHER IT'S A NET
CAST TOO BROADLY THE REALITY IS
THAT THAT'S THE ONLY WAY THAT
YOU -- CAN
REALLY LITTLE BIT OURSELVES OF
THE SCOURGE THE TYPES OF
MEASURES THAT YES MAYBE A FEW.
EMPLOY UP TO REALLY TREAT THEIR
EMPLOYEES HORRIBLY BUT THIS IS
NOT JUST A ONE OFF OR WHERE IT'S
ONLY AFFECTING ONE SPECIFIC
INDUSTRY OR ONE REGION OF OUR
STATE.
AND THAT'S WHY IT'S THIS KIND OF
SITUATION WHERE --
YOU WANTED A PRICE A PLAY
BROTHER YOU WANT PROSECUTORS TO
HAVE THE ABILITY. TO KEEP THEIR
COMMUNITIES SAFE IN A WAY THAT
THAT -- THAT
THEY BELIEVE IS MOST EFFECTIVE
IN SO I APPRECIATE --
HAVING --
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE DISK
TRAINS ABSENTIA YEARS WELL AND
WITH THAT --
ALASKA MEMBER TO CLOSE AND AGAIN
I RECOMMENDATION.
I JUST WANNA ADDRESS SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION --
AS FAR AS THE SPECIAL DECKS
DISTRICTS AND NO RECORD OF A
PUBLIC EMPLOYEE EMPLOYER.
I'M COMMITTEE IN --
LABOR TRACK CORRECT BUT I DO
WANT TO GO BACK AND CHECK I KNOW
THAT THERE WERE SOME PROBLEMS.
BELIEVE WAS WITH --
IT WAS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
CONTRACTING WITH SOMEBODY THAT
WAS DOING THAT SO WE WERE WERE
WILLING TO TAILOR THE BILL TO
NOT HAVE AN ONEROUS A FACT BUT
THERE MIGHT BE A NEED --
FOR THE STATE TO ENSURE THAT
THOSE PEOPLE THEIR CONTRACTING
WITH ACTUALLY TO FILL THEIR
OBLIGATIONS UNDER THE LAW --
BUT I DO JUST WANT TO GO DOUBLE
CHECK THAT THERE'S NO --
EXPERIENCE OF THIS HAPPENING IN
SOME SMALL CITY --
AREA THAT WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT --
IT WITH REACHED WITH REGARDS TO
THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE WHERE YOU
LIVE I'D BE HAPPY TO TAKE.
A SPECIFIC SPECIFIC LANGUAGE
FROM THE CHAMBER THAT GETS TO
THEIR VERY VERY VERY NARROW --
SITUATIONS LIKE A PROPERTY
MANAGER WHOSE JOB IT IS TO LIVE
ON SITE BUT THAT PROVISION IS
VERY IMPORTANT --
IN IN EXPLAINING TO WORKERS --
ESPECIALLY IMMIGRANT WORKERS WHO
HAVE HAD THINGS TAKEN FROM AND
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE TO LIVE --
TWENTY PEOPLE TO AN APARTMENT --
WITHOUT THE RIGHT TO COME AND GO
AS THEY PLEASE SO WE DON'T WANT
TO TAKE OUT THAT PROVISION BUT
IF THERE IS SOME KIND OF
ACCEPTING LANGUAGE THAT THEY'D
LIKE I'D BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
THEM ON THAT.
OTHERWISE --
I THINK WE HAVE A REALLY GOOD.
THANK YOU SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION
TO PASSAGE ASSURED OF KALRA
PLEASE.
DO PASSED TO JUDICIARY KALRA AYE
KALRA AYE FLORA.
CARILLO.
I DEEP.
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I JONES
SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE THREE OF US
THREE OF US HI.
HI THE BILLS OUT
[inaudible]
SHE THE CIVIC CENTER
BOB.
JUST.
ONE MOMENT YOUR YEAH YEAH
SUBCOMMITTEE PRISTINE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KALRA WHICH BILL
WOULD YOU LIKE 2% FIRST YOU HAVE
AB THIRTY FIVE IN AB FIVE TWENTY
BY TWENTY PLEASE OKAY GREAT.
ALL RIGHT OF YOU READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M PROUD TO PRESENT AB
FIVE TWENTY WHICH DEFINES WHEN A
PUBLIC SUBSIDY IS DE MINIMUS FOR
THE PURPOSE OF DETERMINING.
IF THE PREVAILING WAGE APPLIES A
PRIVATE PROJECTS USING PUBLIC
FUNDS.
THERE'S A MOTION BY SOMEONE
MEMBER GONZALEZ SECOND BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REQUESTS.
THIS BILL PROVIDES THAT A PUBLIC
SUB SUBSIDY ON A PRIVATE PROJECT
IS DE MINIMUS SO LONG AS IT IT
IS LESS THAN TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND LESS THAN 2% OF THE TOTAL
PROJECT COST.
UNDER CURRENT LAW PROJECT IS NOT
SUBJECT PREVAILING WAGE LAW EVEN
IF IT RECEIVES A PUBLIC SUBSIDY.
IT THAT SUBSIDIES DE MINIMUS IN
THE CONTEXT OF THE PROJECT.
SINCE THE TURN TO TO MINIMIZE
HAS NOT DEFINED AS STATUTE THERE
IS NO GUIDANCE AS TO THE
APPROPRIATE LEVEL PUBLIC SUBSIDY
THAT SHOULD BE CONSIDERED DE
MINIMUS.
THIS HAS LED TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF INDUSTRIAL THEY RULINGS AS TO
WHAT IS DE MINIMUS LEADING TO
CONFUSION AND LITIGATION ABOUT
THE TERM ACTUALLY MEANS. FOR
EXAMPLE IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
THE DEPARTMENT APPROVED AS DE
MINIMUS A ONE POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLAR PUBLIC SUBSIDY TO A
NINETY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
NOT PROCESSING FACILITY PROJECTS
THIS WAS ONLY ONE POINT 75% OF
THE TOTAL PROJECT COST.
A PUBLIC SUBSIDY FOR PRIVATE
PROJECT THAT IS MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS OR 2% OF THE TOTAL
PROJECT COST IS A NOTABLE
TAXPAYER INVESTMENT AND IT IS
REASONABLE TO REQUIRE PREVAILING
WAGES.
IF THE DEVELOPER WANTS A PUBLIC
SUBSIDY OVER THAT AMOUNT.
UNDER THIS BILL NO DEVELOPERS
REQUIRED TO TAKE A PUBLIC
SUBSIDIES SUBSIDY OVER THE
DIMINISHMENT DE MINIMUS AMOUNT
THAT THEY DO NOT WANT TO PAY THE
PREVAILING WAGE.
UP HOLDING A PREVAILING WAGE
LAWS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE THEY
ENSURE THAT CONTRACTORS ARE NOT
AWARDED PUBLIC WORKS CONTRACTS
BY VIRTUE OF PAYING LOW WAGES
AND UNDERCUTTING COMPETITORS.
UP WITH DATA RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I VOTE AND I HAVE WITH ME
JEREMY SMITH WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES.
A SMALL THANK YOU THANK YOU --
MISTER KALRA FOR THAT EXCELLENT
SUMMATION OF THE BILL JEREMY
SMITH HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL THE SPONSOR.
OF THIS LEGISLATION.
I'M NOT TOTALLY A FREEWARE
WASN'T HERE THEN BUT IN TWO
THOUSAND ONE I'M NOT FAMILIAR
WITH LEGISLATIVE HISTORY IN.
TWO THOUSAND ONE THE TERM TO
MINIMIZE WAS PUT INTO THE LABOR
CODE INTO THE PREVENT WAY JACKED
IN THE EXCEPTIONS SECTION OF THE
RULING WAGE.
AND IT WASN'T A FINE BECAUSE
NOBODY BACK AND THOUGHT THEY
NEEDED TO DEFINE IT THERE IS A
LEGAL DEFINITION OF WORK THOUGH.
IT IS QUOTE TRIFLING I OVERLOOK
IT.
pUNFORTUNATELY THE FACT THAT
THERE IS NOT A DEFINITION AND
THE PREVAILING WAGE ACT FOR THIS
TERM HAS LED TO AS OPEN A
LOOPHOLE --
THAT HAS BEEN EXPLOITED
UNFORTUNATELY --
BY.
OF FOR PROFIT PRIVATE DEVELOPERS --
MISTER KALRA GIVE A VERY GOOD
EXAMPLE --
OF D. I. R. DETERMINATION --
OF A VERY LARGE AMOUNT OF PUBLIC
MONEY THAT WENT TO A PROJECT
THAT DID NOT THEN TRIGGERED THE
BRICK BRICK PREVAILING WAGE --
THERE WAS ANOTHER ONE TWENTY
SIXTEEN THAT WAS FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANOTHER ONE IN --
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THAT WAS OVER
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
SO THERE'S A REAL ISSUE HERE --
WE NEED A DEFINITION --
FOR THIS TERM --
WAGES MEANT --
TO IT IS TAXPAYER DOLLARS THAT
GO TO A PROJECT AND WE BELIEVE
TAXPAYER DOLLARS SHOULD GO TO
PAYING NOT ONLY THE PREVAILING
WAGE.
BUT IT'S REALLY A LIVING WAGE AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW --
WAGES BENEFITS THAT ARE IN LINE
WITH THE MIDDLE CLASS LIVELIHOOD.
AND CONSTRUCTION WORKERS DESERVE
THAT AND TAXPAYERS DESERVE TO
KNOW THEIR TAX DOLLARS ARE GOING
TO PAY CONSTRUCTION WORKERS.
A REAL LIVING WAGE OF FOR THOSE
REASONS WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MIKE MONNA
GOING TO BE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS A CALIFORNIA STATE I
TRADES COUNCIL.
MR SIX COUNTS OF SHEET METAL
WORKERS AND THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION ELEVATOR CONSTRUCTORS --
THIS BILL HAS BEEN THROUGH THIS
COMMITTEE BEFORE AND HOPEFULLY
THIS WILL HAVE A GOOD RESOLUTION
ALL.
WHICH DUGGAR CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
HEY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SILVIO FOR ARI --
HERE ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
JUST TO MAKE SURE WE SEPARATED
WHERE THE RESIDENTIAL HOME
BUILDERS SO WHEN YOU GUYS A
REFERENCE SEEN.
NOT MANUFACTURING PLANTS AND
HOSPITALS LIKE IN THE FACT SHEET
THAT'S NOT US WHERE THE
RESIDENTIAL HOME BUILDERS --
AND UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE HERE --
IN OPPOSITION THIS BILL TODAY.
TO BE CLEAR WE ARE NOT IN
OPPOSITION TO THE 2% THRESHOLD
THAT IS IN THE BILL.
WE ARE VERY CONCERNED THAT THE
TWO HUNDRED SAN TRIGGER WILL
MAKE A NUMBER OF PARTNERSHIPS
THAT WE HAVE WITH THE STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. TO TRY TO
PUSH PUBLIC POLICY INITIATIVES --
MAKE THAT VERY VERY DIFFICULT --
A COUPLE EXAMPLES AND WANT TO
PUT OUT THERE FOR YOU GUYS FIRST
AGAIN AS NEW RESIDENTIAL
BUILDERS.
NEW HOME CONSTRUCTION IN A
NUMBER OF AVENUES IS LOOKING TO
PUSH THE ENVELOPES ON ENERGY
EFFICIENCY WATER CONSERVATION.
RENEWABLE GENERATION BATTERY
STORAGE AND GET THOSE
TECHNOLOGIES INTO THE MARKET
PLACE -- TO
INCORPORATE THOSE TECHNOLOGIES
THEY HAVE TO BE COST EFFECTIVE
MANY OF THOSE TECHNOLOGIES AT
THIS POINT TIME ARE NOT.
SO THE VERY OFTEN COME WITH A
REBATE AND INCENTIVE SOMETHING
THAT BRINGS THAT TECHNOLOGY TO A
LEVEL THAT IT CAN BE
INCORPORATED AS A STANDARD
FEATURE ACROSS THE ENTIRE
PROJECT --
IF THIS TOTAL SOME OF THOSE
REBATES OR INCENTIVES.
TRIGGER THE PREVAILING WAGE WILL
INSTANTLY ALL THE SAID THE
ENTIRE PROJECT IS NOW PREVAILING
WAGE AND WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
COST THAT FAR EXCEED.
THE SOME OF THOSE INCENTIVES AND
REBATES SO AT THE END OF THE DAY
WE WILL JUST FOR GO INSTALLING
THOSE TECHNOLOGIES AND NOT GET
THOSE ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS
INTO THE MARKET PLACE.
SECOND --
MORE AND MORE BUILDERS ARE BEING
LOOKED TO TO HELP TRY TO AS PART
OF A CURRENT --
DEVELOPMENT PROJECT GET RICHARD
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS THIS IS
HAPPENING MORE AND MORE AS THE
STATE IS LOCAL GOVERNMENT LOOKS
TO GET PROJECTS GOING IN URBAN
CORES CITY CENTERS.
SO YOU'LL HAVE A PROJECT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WILL APPROACH YOU AND
SAY HEY.
WE HAVE AN ANTICIPATION THAT
THESE FUTURE PROJECTS ARE GOING
TO TAKE PLACE WE WOULD LIKE YOU
AS PART OF THIS PROJECT TO GET
INFRASTRUCTURE WATER SEWER.
UTILITIES STREET LIGHTS CURB
GUTTER AND SIDEWALK WE WOULD
LIKE THAT STUFF TO BE OVERSIZED
TOO SO WE CAN APPROPRIATELY
HANDLE THOSE FUTURE PROJECTS.
AND WE WILL SAY OKAY WE'RE HAPPY
TO HELP YOU WITH THAT AND THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WILL REIMBURSE
THE DEVELOPER THE BUILDER FOR
THE PORTION OF THE PROJECT THAT
IS TO THE BENEFIT OF TOSE
FUTURE PROJECTS SO IT'S NOT TO
THE BENEFIT.
OF THE FIRST IN PROJECT --
DOING THAT HAS HUGE BENEFITS FOR
EVERYBODY IN THE COMMUNITY SO --
YOU CAN IMAGINE THAT GETTING --
ALL THE WORK ASSOCIATED WITH
TEARING UP STREETS AND SIDEWALKS
AND NOISE AND TRAFFIC GETTING
ALL THAT STUFF DONE FIRST
RELIEVES IT FOR THOSE FUTURE
PROJECTS SO WHETHER IT'S THE
HOMEOWNERS LIVING IN THE AREA --
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE TO CONTEND
WITH THEIR STREETS AND SIDEWALKS
BEING TORN UP WE CAN GET THOSE
THINGS ACCOMPLISHED FIRST --
AND EARLY IN THE PROJECT
DEVELOPMENT.
SO AGAIN YOU KNOW WE ARE NOT --
HERE OPPOSING ALL THE ASPECTS OF
THE BILL WE BELIEVE THAT THE 2% --
IN OUR VIEW HAS BEEN WELL INTO
DISCUSSED IN THE IT'S BEEN VERY
CLEAR THAT EVEN OVER TIME IN THE
LAST EIGHTEEN YEARS.
THAT CONSTRUCTION COSTS CONTINUE
TO RISE AND I THINK WE'RE ALL
WELL AWARE OF THAT.
SO EVEN WITH THAT WE EXPECT
CONSTRUCTION COSTS ARISE IN THE
FUTURE AND SO WE STRUGGLE WITH
THE THOUGHT OF HAVING A HARD AND
FAST NUMBER IN STATUTE IN PLACE
AND IT NOT BE A PERCENTAGE OF OF
CONSTRUCTION SO. FOR THOSE
REASONS --
WE OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU THERE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
DO WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL.
OPPOSITION.
AT THE TIME MISTER DICKEY.
YES -- THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR OF I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR THE FOR THE AUTHOR
IS THAT --
WOULD --
WOULD HE BE OPEN --
TO JUST STICKING WITH THE 2% AND
AND MAYBE NOT A NOT NOT PUT A
FIXED NUMBER --
NOT PUT A FIXED DOLLAR AMOUNT ON
THE BILL.
BECAUSE THINGS DO CHANGE AND
WITHIN --
FOUR THAT THAT TWO EIGHTY
THOUSAND ALL SEEM AWFULLY LOW.
WELL UP THANKS FOR THE QUESTION
THE SEVERITY OF THE THE PROBLEM
AS EXEMPLIFIED BY WHAT BUT ONE
OF THE EXAMPLES IS THE THE
PROCESSING FACILITY I HAD THAT --
COST NINETY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
SINCE THE SUBSIDY WAS ONE POINT
SIX MILLION IT ONLY AMOUNTED TO
ONE POINT 75%.
AND SO I THINK THAT THE PROBLEM
WITH THE PERCENTAGES THAT.
YOU'LL PROJECTS OF THE SIZE OF
THE PROJECT IS NOT NESTLE
ACCOUNTED FOR AND THE REALITY IS
THAT I PERSONALLY BELIEVE THAT
IF THERE'S AT ANY AMOUNT OF
PUBLIC SUBSIDIES SUBSIDY.
THAT IS OF A SIGNIFICANT VALUE
AND I I BELIEVE TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS IS
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF TAXPAYER
MONEY -- A
PUBLIC SUBSIDY AND SO I'M I'M
GOING TO STICK TO THAT I'M OPEN
TO SUGGESTIONS --
GOING FORWARD THOUGH --
BUT BUT I I DO BELIEVE THAT'S A
CRITICAL COMPONENT OF THE BILL
IT IS NOT JUST A PERCENTAGE BUT
THE ACTUAL AMOUNT AND I THINK
THAT I BELIEVE TUNERS ANY BY
THOUSANDS OF PARAMOUNT. TO BE A
FOUNDATIONAL AMOUNT IN TERMS OF
WHAT PUT THE PUBLIC SHOULD
EXPECT IN TERMS OF THE QUALITY --
IN KIND OF A WAIT.
IF IF THAT IS THE CASE WITH AND
AND WE DON'T WANT TO DO IT RIGHT
NOW BUT WOULD YOU BE OPEN --
TO PUTTING IN SOME SORT OF LAW
THAT WILL ALLOW THAT THAT FIX
DOLLAR TO RISE WITH INFLATION
EVERY YEAR.
I'M OPEN.
TO ANY SUGGESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE I'M I'M CERTAINLY WILLING
TO LISTEN.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU KNOW OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THE CHERRY MY CLOSE.
THANK YOU UP IN AN ODD TO SAY
THAT A LOOK YOU KNOW I I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS GOING ON AT THE CITY
LEVELS TO TRY TO INCENTIVIZE --
NEW TECHNOLOGIES WHAT HAVE YOU
AND AND AND INFRASTRUCTURE BUT
IF INCENTIVIZING NEW
TECHNOLOGIES INTO NEW POP UP
INTO NEW PROJECT CHOIRS PAYMENT
ALL AGES THAT WE NEED TO FIND
ANOTHER WAY. TO INCENTIVIZE HE'S
PROJECTS AND NOT ON THE BACKS
THE WORKERS AND SO --
I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION --
AND REALLY OF US --
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IF I TWENTY ENJOYS AN
AYE RECOMMENDATION WITH A DO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA.
I'VE KALRA HI FLORA CARILLO HI
CARILLO I DEEP HI.
I HI THANK YOU ALYSSA.
THANK YOU.
NOW YOU HAVE A BE.
THIRTY FIVE THANK YOU --
THANK YOU FOR THE HEY.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A THIRTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
SALAS SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
AB THIRTY FIVE TODAY AND I DO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE A MAN'S.
I A HOME AND A LOT AND I'M
REALLY HAPPY TO BE JOINED BY A
COLLEAGUES AS SOME MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA DOES PUT.
A WORKPLACE SAFETY --
MY HAVE YOU GUYS BEEN A PRIORITY
OF HERS FOR I EVEN BEFORE I
ARRIVED HERE IN THIS BUILDING SO
I'M GRATEFUL TO BE PARTNERING
WITH ON THIS --
AB THIRTY FIVE WOULD IMPROVE HOW
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS ARE MADE
AWARE OF AND HANDLE CASES OF
LEAD POISONING AMONG WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND WOULD HELP PREVENT REPEATED
OR PROLONGED INCIDENTS OF THAT
PLACING A WORKPLACES.
LED POSING CAN CAUSE HIGH BLOOD
PRESSURE COGNITIVE DIFFICULTIES
RESULT IN MISCARRIAGES A PRIMER
PREMATURE BIRTHS.
IN PREGNANT WOMEN AND ALSO
BECAUSE THE REVERSIBLE DAMAGE TO
OUR NERVOUS SYSTEM AND KIDNEYS.
AS WE ALL KNOW LED CAN HAVE
PROFOUND AND PERMANENT ADVERSE
HEALTH EFFECTS IN BOTH CHILDREN
LEAD POISONING CAN BE FATAL.
WHILE THERE IS NO SAFE BLOOD
LEAD LEVEL THE CDC SAYS THAT --
THAT LEVELS OF TWENTY FIVE
MICROGRAMS CHRIS SAFETY SHOULD
BE A PRIORITY FOR ALL BUSINESSES
IN THIS BILL SIMPLY REQUIRES CAL
OSHA TO LOOK INTO WORK SITES
THAT WORKERS WITH ELEVATED BLOOD
LEAD LEVELS.
THIS IS A MODEST COMMONSENSE
APPROACH TO HELP ENSURE THAT
PROPER NOTIFICATIONS OF FOLLOW
UP BETWEEN DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND CAL OSHA ARE MADE IN
ORDER PROTECT PRESERVE PRESENT
AND FUTURE WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES --
AND AGAIN I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE AND WOULD BE A WILL
BE TURNING IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE IN SOME REGARDS YET
WAS ALSO GONNA --
SHARE A STORY THAT WE SHARED
LAST YEAR ABOUT THE CONSEQUENCES
OF NOT DOING ENOUGH IS A STATE.
THANK YOU I'M A CO AUTHOR TO
THIS IMPORTANT BILL BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THAT IF THAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN IN PLACE TWENTY YEARS AGO
EXCEPT WOULD HAVE BEEN SHIPPED
ON A REALLY LONG TIME AGO AND AS
WE STARTED DOING THE WORK AND WE
WERE CARRYING ABOUT CONSTITUENTS
ARE SAFE WE SAY.
SOUTH THE QUESTION OF WHAT'S
GOING ON WITH OUR EMPLOYEES AND
DID WE DID WE PROTECT THEM --
AND SO I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT I
WANT TO THANK.
MISTER KALRA FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
ON THIS BUT I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO READ A LETTER FROM A
FORMER EXCITE WORKER.
AND I'LL LEAVE MY AYE TESTIMONY
AT THAT.
OUR NAMES ARE LESHAN AN ELVEN
RICHARDSON WE WANT TO THANK
MISTER KALRA FOR INTRODUCING AB.
TWENTY NINE SIXTY THREE WE KNOW
FROM PERSONAL EXPERIENCE HOW
IMPORTANT IS LEGISLATION IS TO
PROTECT FUTURE AND CURRENT
WORKERS FROM LEAD POISONING
HURTING THEIR LIVES.
ALVIN STARTED WORKING AT THE
RENDON PLANTS IN THE EARLY
NINETEEN NINETIES.
AFTER A FEW YEARS WORKING IN
THIS MULTI ROOM ALVIN STARTED
EXPERIENCING SYMPTOMS WE NOW
KNOW RELATED TO LEAD.
EARLY ON IT WAS SMALL THINGS.
PROBLEMS WITHOUT.
LATER THE ISSUE GOT MORE SERIOUS
ALVIN SPEECH BECAME SLURRED.
THERE WAS THIS LOAN IS ABOUT HIM
HE SEEMED TRAINED AND SLUGGISH.
YOU MAY ASK WHY WOULD ANYONE
STATE A JOB LIKE THAT.
THE TRUTH IS I ALVIN SIMPLY
NEEDED A PAYCHECK IN MAYBE A
TRUSTED TOO MUCH WE WERE
FREQUENTLY LET TESTED.
WHEN MY NUMBERS GOT TOO HIGH I
WOULD BE SENT HOME OR PUT ON
WHAT WAS CALLED LIKE DUTY?
THAT WAS MOSTLY OUTSIDE PAINTED
WORK.
WHEN THE LEVELS CAME DOWN A LIST
BACK THIS MULTI ROOM IT WENT ON
LIKE THIS UNTIL I FINALLY LEFT
THE COMPANY IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN WHEN THE SYMPTOMS GOT TOO
BAD?
WE BETTER REASON INVESTIGATIVE
STORY AND IT WAS VERY HURTFUL TO
LEARN THAT CAL OSHA EXCUSE TO
HIGH LEVELS OF LEAD THAT ALVIN
ANOTHER EX HAD WORKERS ARE
CONSTANTLY EXPOSED.
TO SHOULD BE TREATED LIKE THEIR
DISPOSABLE THAT'S NOT WHAT
AMERICA OR CALIFORNIA IS
SUPPOSED TO BE ABOUT.
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR SUPPORTING
THIS IMPORTANT BILL AND FOR
MAKING CALIFORNIA A BETTER PLACE.
TO OTHER FAMILIES DON'T HAVE TO
ENDURE THE PAIN WE HAVE
SINCERELY ALVIN ELLIS ON
RICHARDSON.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AS A MEMBER WE HAVE
BILL ALL YOU THE CALIFORNIA
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP.
I THANK YOU OF THIS THIS IS A
REPEAT OF THE BILL --
WHITES NEEDED IS BECAUSE WORKERS
IN CALIFORNIA TODAY.
AND THAT'S CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH HAS RARELY
REFERRED THEM TO CAL OSHA.
THE BILL DOES NOT REQUIRE
CALLOUSLY TO FIND ANYONE OR SITE
THEM IT JUST GET SOME TO GO AND
INVESTIGATE THAT'S THE IMPORTANT
THING.
WAS VETOED LAST YEAR FOR TWO
REASONS BOTH OF WHICH WERE
ERRONEOUS ONENESS IT CITED THE
PENDING REGULATIONS BY CAL OSHA.
AND THAT WAS INDEED THE SUBJECT
OF A BILL HEARD A FEW MINUTES
AGO AB FOR FIFTY SEVEN BY MISTER
QUIRK.
THAT IS ABOUT LEAD LEVELS IN THE
AIR DOES NOTHING TO DO WITH
BLOOD LEVELS AS NOTHING DO
REFERRALS SEPARATE BILLS
SEPARATE ISSUES SO IMPROPER
REASON FREDO THERE AND THE OTHER
IT'S SAD.
THIS BILL WOULD HURT CD PH IS
TRADITION OF WORKING
COOPERATIVELY WITH EMPLOYERS
WHAT TURNS OUT THEY SAY THEY DO
BUT THEY JUST DON'T GET ANYTHING
DONE.
THIS QUE THIS BILL ROSE OUT OF A
LOCAL CASE A GUN RANGER IN CITY
SACRAMENTO A FRIEND IS
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER DID.
AND FOUND OUT THAT WAS ABOUT TEN
YEARS THAT PEOPLE HAVE BEEN LEAD
POISON THERE.
THE CAL --
CD PH HAD WORK COOPERATIVELY
WITH THE EMPLOYER THE CITY
SACRAMENTO FOR YEAR AFTER YEAR
AND MEANWHILE PEOPLE GETTING
LEAD POISON WE CAN GIVE YOU
DOZENS AND DOZENS OF BUSINESSES
THAT STILL HAPPENING TODAY.
WHERE THEY'RE STILL GETTING
SPIKED LED POISONINGS AND CAL CD
PH SITS ON THOSE AND SAYS WERE
WORKING COOPERATIVELY WITH THE
EMPLOYER THIS BILL DOES SAYS
TURN OVER TO CAL OSHA IF THEY'RE
REALLY HIGH BLOOD LEVELS?
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO ENFORCE
THAT IF THIS BILL WAS IN PLACE
WE MIGHT HAVE AVOIDED AN EXCITED
BUT THERE'S ANOTHER LARGE BATTER
RECYCLER IN --
LA NOW QUIT MEXICO WHICH HAS
DOZENS OF LEAD POISONED WORKERS
WE ALSO SHOOTING RANGES PAINT
PAINTING COMPANY SAM BLASTING
THEY'RE WORKING WITH LEAD THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IT'S A
REALLY SIMPLE BILL.
AND CV PH WE HOPE WIL SAY WE'RE
OKAY WITH IT THIS YEAR IT'S
SIMPLE FOR THEM TO TURN THESE
NUMBERS THESE HUMAN FIGURES OVER
TO CAL OSHA FOR ACTION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THE DEARBORN REPRESENTING FIVE
THOUSAND BOARD CERTIFIED
PEDIATRICIANS AND PEDIATRIC SUB
SPECIALISTS WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
IF.
MITCH DYER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO TRANSPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MATT BROUGHT WITH THE TEAMSTERS
A. T. A UNITED HERE MACHINE S.
C. S. C. IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BRENNAN DAWSON WITH SIERRA CLUB
IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
RENEE BAYARDO SEIU CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
CHECK A CLICK ISSUES MECHANISTIC
NINE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
HAVE A VERY BUSY FIRST WEEK.
YES THANK YOU.
AGAIN ROBERT WHICH WE FOR THE
CAL CHAMBER WE ARE OPPOSED AB --
THIRTY FIVE OUR CONCERN IS AB
THIRTY FIVE YOU SERBS OSHA'S
TRADITIONAL RULEMAKING ROLLING
BUT ALSO CREATE CONTRA
RESTRAINED IT'S GOING FORWARD.
I'M IN LIGHT OF WHAT WAS
DISCUSSED JUST A MOMENT AGO AS
NOTED UNDER EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY
SEVEN THERE IS A ONGOING RULE
MAKING PROCESS THAT WE THINK%
THIS.
THIS GETS IN THE WAY OF TWO I'M
REALLY REFERENCE BACK TO THE
GOVERNOR BROWN TO VETO MESSAGE
OF A BETWEEN NINE SIXTY THREE
LAST YEAR.
INSIDE THE SAME CONCERNS AND IF
I COULD BRIEFLY I'M I BELIEVE
THAT ONE OF THE POINTS MADE --
IN SUPPORT ABOUT --
THE PRIOR BILL FORTY SEVEN THAT
WE JUST HEARD IS IS IN CORRECTED.
I MAY HAVE MISUNDERSTOOD BUT I
BELIEVE THE COMMENT WAS THAT
THAT APPLY TO USE ONE TOPIC
WHICH WAS JUST THE AIR --
HAVING SPOKEN TO THE AUTHOR ON
FORTY SEVEN I BELIEVE THE INTENT
IS TO AMEND THAT TO INCLUDE ALL
OF THE TOPICS THE NEW
REGULATIONS WILL COVER.
SO I BELIEVE THAT ACTUALLY ITIS
BROADER THAN --
THEN WHAT WAS STATED HEARING
WILL ADDRESS MORE ISSUES --
TRYING TO OURS AND I HOPE I DID
MISUNDERSTAND A COMMON BUT
TURNING TO OUR TO SPECIFIC
CONCERNS.
FIRST -- IN
HOW THIS WILL CREATE A
CONTRADICTORY RELATION TO THE
PRESENT STANDARDS --
THE PRESENT STANDARDS IN AGAIN
THEY MAY CHANGE BUT THE CONCERN
WILL STILL APPLY --
THE PRESENT STANDARDS UNDER OSHO
REQUIRE --
BLOOD TESTING AND I'LL I'LL TRY
TO BE CLEAR AT THIS A BLOOD
TESTING --
CAN BE ENDED IF IT IS FOR TWO
TESTS IN A ROW WORKERS BLOOD
LEVELS BELOW THIRTY MICROGRAMS.
I'M HERE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TESTING DPH BEING REQUIRED TO
FORWARD TO OSHA AND SHOULD
CONSIDER A SERIOUS VIOLATION.
AT A LEVEL OF TWENTY FIVE I
BELIEVE THE MOMENTS WERE --
TWENTY TWENTY MICROGRAMS SO
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT COMPELLING
OSHA TO DO AN URGENT
INVESTIGATION AT A LEVEL BELOW
WHAT IS PRESENTLY EVEN --
THE LEVEL THAT THE EMPLOYER MUST
KEEP TESTING.
SO AND NOT TO GET INTO THE
MERITS OF THOSE BUT JUST TO SHOW
THAT THAT IS A CONTRADICTORY
STANDARD THE BUSINESS WE HAVE TO
LOOK TO WHEN.
TESTING IS NOT AN ONGOING
REQUIRED AT THIS LEVEL BUT
OSHA'S INVESTIGATION MUST HAPPEN
URGENTLY.
I'M AND THAT CONTRADICTORY
POSSIBILITY MIGHT EXIST GOING
FORWARD AND FUTURE REGULATIONS
AS WELL AGAIN THOSE HAVEN'T BEEN
FINALIZED BUT THAT IS OUR
CONCERN THAT THIS WILL PUT
CONTRADICTORY REQUIREMENTS IN
FRONT OF EMPLOYERS --
SECOND I BELIEVE THE PRESENT
TENSE OF OF THE BILL DOES NOT
LEAVE SPACE --
FOR DPH TO DETERMINE THAT THE
LEVEL OF LEAD WHICH IS AN ISSUE --
IS BECAUSE FROM THE WORKPLACE --
WE MENTION THIS BRIEFLY
PREVIOUSLY BUT AGAIN.
IS IT THE NATURE OF LEAD PAINT
IN CALIFORNIA HOMES IS SOMETHING
THIS COMMITTEE IS IS WELL AWARE
OF AND RIGHTLY CONCERNED WITH.
AND COMPELLING OSHA TO
INVESTIGATE COMPELLING IN
PLAYERS TO WORK WITH THAT BUT
WHEN THE SOURCE OF THE LEAD MAY
NOT EVEN BE THE WORKPLACE IS A
CONCERN FOR US IN TERMS OF BIRD --
SO.
EARLY MAKE SURE OF YEAH FOR THAT
REASON -- WE
ARE OPPOSED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
HEARING NONE ARE THERE ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MISS GONZALEZ.
I'M.
WHAT IS AN OKAY LEVEL OF LETTING
YOUR BLOOD?
NO NO LEVEL IS OKAY ACTUALLY LET
ME BE CLEAR IT ALL MAKES YOU
SICK AND IF YOU'RE A MINOR AND
IT'S IT'S ALSO IMPRESS YOUR
COGNITIVE ABILITIES --
BUT THE A CH PD IS LOOKING AT
TWENTY MICROGRAMS WHICH IS IN
LINE WITH WHAT THIS BILL HOUSE.
OKAY SO PERHAPS THE OSHA
STANDARD --
FOR RETESTING OR CONTINUE
TESTING --
NEED IS OUTDATED WE NEED TO
REDUCE THAT AS WELL MIGHT BE
SUBJECT TO FUTURE BILLS AND AND
OF THE SUMMER GONZALEZ THE
CLEARLY THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
ONE WHICH REDUCES IT WOULD
TWENTY FIVE MILLIGRAMS TWENTY
MILLIGRAMS IS PER DISCUSSIONS
WITH CAL OSHA AND THERE'S
ANOTHER AMENDMENT WHICH HAS
PEREMPTORY LAYOUT LANGUAGE
SHOULD CAL OSHA ADOPT STRICTER
RAGS IN THE FUTURE WE DON'T HAVE
COME BACK ANOTHER BILL.
THEY SAY IT'S FIFTEEN THEN THIS
WILL MOVE WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF CALLOW SHOW
SO THIS IS REALLY AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO NOT JUST GET IT RIGHT
TODAY.
BUT MAKE SURE THAT AND THE GOING
INTO THE FUTURE THAT CAL OSHA IS
THE ONE THAT'S MAKING THE
DETERMINATION SPACE ON THE
SCIENCE AND THEIR ABILITY TO
INVESTIGATE.
MADAM CHAIR IF I COULD ADD WITH
CHILDREN INFANTS PREGNANT WOMEN
REALLY LOW LEVELS ARE
PERMANENTLY HARMFUL THEY LOWER
I. Q. AS YOU KNOW YOU DID IT THE
BILL ON TESTING SCHOOLS.
WITH ADULTS OR THE CHANCE TO
IMPROVE AND THEY THEY OFTEN
REMOVE THE WORKER FROM THE
SOURCE WHICH IS ALMOST ALWAYS.
THE WITH OF SOURCE A PLACE TO
WORK NOT THE HOME BUT SOMETIMES
IT IS THE HOME AND THEY CAN
IMPROVE IF THEY GET BACK UP
AGAIN THEY'RE TAKEN OUT OF THE
WORKPLACE.
BUT THAT'S WHAT CALLUSES GOOD
I'VE READ THE PROPOSED RAGS THE
SUBJECT MISTER COURSE BILL
THEY'RE GOOD THEY'RE STRONG BUT
AGAIN IT'S APPLES AND ORANGES
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IN AB.
NINE THIRTY FIVE PURSES FOR
FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU FOR THE ANSWER
THAT WAS OBVIOUSLY A QUESTION
THAT I AS CLOSE TO AN ANSWER TO
BUT I JUST WANTED TO MAKE THE
POINT WHEN I THINK THE CHAMBER --
FOR BRINGING OUT THE DEFICIENCY
IN THE CALLUSES STANDARD AND I'M
SURE THEY'LL BE SUPPORTIVE WHEN
THEY'RE LINED.
UP.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
OBVIOUSLY AS WE CONTINUE --
THE VERY VITAL TASK OF
IDENTIFYING WHEN PEOPLE DO HAVE
LEAD IN THEIR BLOOD I MEAN FROM
A COMMUNITY WHERE IT COULD BE
FROM A NUMBER OF SOURCES THAT
COULD BE FROM MARKET COULD BE
FROM.
HOME IT COULD BE FROM A VARIETY
OF THINGS THAT THAT THE THE
WHATEVER IT COMES FROM --
REMEDIATING NOT STOPPING IS A
HUGE THING SO THANK YOU THIS
IMPORTANT BILL --
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE MISTER CHAIR YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU.
OF A INTO JUSTIN'S BUT TO ADD ON
TO THE FINAL POINT HERE IN TERMS
OF WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS REALLY
THE REFERRAL WHICH IS CRITICAL
REFERRAL FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. TO CAL OSHA
DOESN'T COMPEL A PARTICULAR
RESULT OF THE INVESTIGATION THAT
CAL OSHA DO THEIR JOB AND THEY
WANT TO DO THEIR JOB.
THEY CAN'T DO THEIR JOB IF THEY
DON'T HAVE THE INFORMATION THING
THAT INFORMATION TO THEM IN A
TIMELY FASHION.
LET THEM.
DO THEIR INVESTIGATION AND IF
IT'S NOT DUE TO THE WORKPLACE WE
CAN FIGURE OUT WHAT IS DUE TO
THIS TO THE WORKPLACE I THINK IT
EVEN BENEFITS EMPLOYERS AND
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER WHEN
THE PROBLEM BECOMES MUCH MORE
WORSE A MUCH MORE DIFFICULT TO
MITIGATE.
AS WITH THAT I RESPECT THE
ASPIRIN ABOVE.
THANK YOU AND JUST TO BE CLEAR
MISTER CHAIR YOU ARE TAKING YOUR
OWN COMMITTEES.
I YES I AM TAKING MY OWN
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS --
AND AND I I ALSO WANT TO THANK
MY JOINT AUTHORS AMBER GARCIA --
FOR JOINING ME IN THIS EFFORT
THANK YOU PHIL ENJOYS AYE
RECOMMENDATION TO DO PATH MEANT
THAT TO APPROPRIATIONS
BENEFACTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA.
I'D KALRA AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO CARILLO HI CARILLO I
DEEP.
NO NO.
GONZALEZ OKAY GONZALEZ I JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER I THREE OF
US.
THREE OF US HI.
OKAY.
THANK YOU IS AN AMERICAN REAL.
FOR LEADING THE LAST COUPLE
ITEMS AND NOW WE CAN DO I DON'T
THINK ALL THE BILLS ARE OUTSIDE
ANY ADD ONS FOR THOSE THAT WERE --
ABSENT.
THINK ABOUT IT SECTOR.
CONSENT CALENDAR AB TWO SIXTY
SEVEN AND FIVE NINETY THREE
ABSENT MEMBERS DEEP.
DO YOU I JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER HI.
AB FOUR FIFTY SEVEN ABSENT
MEMBERS DEEP.
NEED NOT VOTING JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER HI.
SB FIVE TWENTY ABSENT MEMBERS
FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING JONES SAWYER
JONES SAWYER HI.
AB [inaudible]
FIVE EIGHTY NINE FLORA.
FLORA I DEEP.
DO YOU I YES.
I THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH THANK
YOU MADAM SECTOR BEERS AND